[Musique]
au piquet mais c'est vachement
impressionnant je vais à 100 par la sécu
hamel qui nous aura pas fait contrôler
dessus on est là parce que
mais comme c'est charnel wali peut-être
si je chante une petite chanson il faut
pas faire de nouveau repoussée derrière
elle a l'air de bien de fiches sauvagine
je me la carcel on peut se casser et
anglais on peut y passer des jours parce
que va maintenant moi je rêve ball entre
les avions le faire du stop sur machin
voter fn parce que moi j'en ai un peu
marre
non jamais
en vendant sur merci aux vents
d'ailleurs
allez on y va rosa dépêche ça va
attendre 1 on a rempli notre mission
[Musique]